I so appreciate you coming to me and  then actually sharing concerns because I  respect that a lot but a conversation it  didn't sit well with me you were talking  about me meeting your family and you  wanted to be able to feel confident and  doing that and it was like referring to  like the bungee jumping thing I told you  I it it wasn't like a sexual thing like  at all but even if it was it's my body I  don't want you ever misunderstand me  I've been so excited because our  relationship has finally been on track I  feel like finally the train is finally  on the track don't know if it's on the  track okay even if it's not I feel like  no I don't know what they can't take  this every single time for you to get to  this point this process doesn't work if  you're not yourself a hundred thousand  percent  [Music]  [Applause]